[Musique]
alors que les médecins en france ont
déjà rencontré de nombreux cas de
personnes atteintes par le cos vite 19
un profil du malade type commence petit
à petit à se dessiner
si on sait que les personnes âgées ou
déjà affaibli par une maladie sont
davantage à risque certains médecins
indique aujourd'hui que l'obésité serait
un vecteur important dans les cas des
complications les plus graves
en effet même chez les plus jeunes
personnes atteintes par le virus celles
qui finissent en réanimation sont en
grande partie des hommes en situation
d'obésité selon un médecin réanimateur à
strasbourg c'est vraiment visible chez
les moins de 50 ans qui sont peu
nombreux dans nos services selon les
études 83 % des patients admis en
réanimation seraient en surpoids un
surpoids dont l' indice de masse
corporelle est supérieur à 35 ce qui
correspond à une obésité sévère mais si
on sait que beaucoup de patients en état
d'obésité sont diabétiques ou victimes
d'hypertension certains se demandent si
ce n'est pas la raison de ces chiffres
très importants chez les personnes en
surpoids ou alors l'école reprise le 11
mai et on a fait un faux si voilà les
personnes atteintes d'obésité sont elles
plus fragiles face au coc u19 ce qu'on a
des éléments là dessus dit me mohamed ou
jean paul amouroux lui de répondre pas
diminué
c'est un élément qui a été constatée
depuis le début de l'épidémie beaucoup
de choses qu'on ne sait pas mais sans
revanche les personnes qui se fait en
état d'obésité avec un indice de masse
corporelle supérieur à 30 voire 35 sont
plus à risque de complication grave
voire très grave et c'est des gens qu'on
retrouve en réanimation et on s'est même
rendu compte que le surpoids est elle si
un facteur de risque donc il suffit pas
d'être obèse tel combien fut imaginée
avec les clichés et les stéréotypes mais
même le surpoids peut être un facteur de
risque alors il peut y avoir deux
éléments de réponse le premier c'est
qu'effectivement quand vous êtes en
surpoids en obésité sévère vous avez des
pathologies associées on s'est rendu
compte que l'hypertension artérielle
était un facteur de risque majeur de
complications ce qui veut donc dire que
ce virus un mode d'action un peu
particulier habituellement quand on
parle d'hypertension de diabète de
surpoids on sait très bien que vous êtes
un peu plus à risque de complications en
ce qui concerne la grippe une pneumonie
mais là c'est vraiment très particulier
il ya un mécanisme qu'on comprend pas
trop comme si le virus avez une affinité
pour les vaisseaux d'ailleurs interrogé
les spécialistes vous allez vous rendre
compte que on a beaucoup parlé d'une
pathologie pulmonaire respiratoires sauf
qu'en fait on se rend compte qu'elle est
respiratoires cette pathologie mais
aussi cardiaque on a des gens qui font
des complications avec des caillots
sanguins des embolies pulmonaires
on a des gens qui ont des manifestations
neurologiques nice attaque le système
nerveux périphérique satin la peau ça
atteint le sang et donc on se rend
compte que c'est une maladie beaucoup
plus complexe que le cerveau il ya enfin
une donnée assez particulière qui est
très déroutant c'est les personnes qui
sont immunodéprimés sous
immunosuppresseurs notamment les
personnes pour été greffé habituellement
en cas d'infection une personne qui est
greffé qui a une très pentu immuno
suppresseurs l'infection et c'est vers
ici et là on constate pas trop ça on a
l'impression est peut-être qu'on se
trompe que ça aurait presque un facteur
protecteur et je ne trahis aucun secret
médical en parlant de pierre menez mais
pierre ménès qui a été greffé deux jours
à 15h59 suis leur essor il a survécu et
on est content qu'il puisse rentrer à la
maison même s'il paraissait vraiment
affaiblis jaïn sous traitement immuno
suppresseurs et mais une idée selon
laquelle au tout début de la maladie
vous avez une infection virale place et
puis et parfois une phase de bactéries
et il ya ce troisièmement dit ce qu'on
appelle un orage cytokines orages
immunologique
en gros il ya une perturbation et
immunologiques très important qui
expliquerait peut-être que certaines
personnes certains patients siouxsie
muno suppresseur irait mieux que les
autres la piste de traitement est là
donc il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on ne
connaît pas mais en tout cas surpoids
hypertension diabète mal équilibrés sont
partis de tous les dix ans des
complications graves du coronavirus même
lorsque vous êtes plus jeunes et ce qui
est dramatique c'est que moi j'ai vu des
gens au sein d'une même famille deux
personnes un homme une femme
souvent les femmes sont plus protégés on
se demande si y'a pas un rôle hormonal
dans cette histoire un homme qui finit
en réanimation voir qu'il décède et puis
la conscience parce que souvent les
malades l'autre tombe malade
eh bien elle qui va bien et donc il ya
une disparité terrible entre deux
malades avec des tout-petits profil qui
peuvent différer une hypertension un
surpoids diabète s'assemblent n'ont pas
condamné mais en tout cas va l'exposer à
beaucoup plus de complications